.
>>> THE HUMAN MIND IS AN
INCREDIBLE THING.
IT CAN CONCEIVE OF THE
MAGNIFICENCE OF THE HEAVENS AND
THE INTRICACIES OF THE BASIC
COMPONENTS OF MATTER.
YET FOR THE MIND TO ACHIEVE ITS
FULL POTENTIAL, IT NEEDS A
SPARK, THE SPARK OF INQUIRY AND
WONDER.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS
BOUNDARIES, NEITHER FOR WHAT WE
CAN DO IN OUR PERSONAL LIVES,
NOR FOR WHAT LIFE AND
INTELLIGENCE AN ACCOMPLISH IN
OUR UNIVERSE.
SO REMEMBER TO LOOK UP AT THE
STARS AND NOT DOWN AT YOUR FEET.
TRY TO MAKE SENSE OF WHAT YOU
SEE AND WONDER ABOUT WHAT MAKES
THE UNIVERSE EXIST.
BE CURIOUS.
♪♪
>>> TONIGHT, LIVE FROM HANGAR
ONE IN NASA RESEARCH CENTER IN
SILICON VALLEY, THE BRIGHTEST
STARS FROM THE WORLDS OF
SCIENCE, TECHNOLOGY, AND
HOLLYWOOD ARE GATHERED TO AWARD
OVER $20 MILLION FOR EXCELLENCE
IN PHYSICS, MATHEMATICS, AND THE
LIFE SCIENCES.
♪♪
>> THIS IS THE BREAK THROUGH
PRIZE, SCIENCES CHANGING THE
WORLD.
PLEASE WELCOME YOUR HOST PIERCE
BROSNAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> LOOK UP.
THOSE WERE THE WORD OF STEPHEN
HAWKING, ONE OF THE GREATEST
MINDS OF OUR TIMES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, THAT MIND WAS
LOST TO THE WORLD, A LOSS TO
SCIENCE AND TO ALL OF HUMANITY.
A LOSS AS WELL TO THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE.
HE WAS NOT ONLY ONE OF OUR
LAUREATES, BUT OUR GUIDING
SPIRIT.
AND YET THAT GUIDING SPIRIT IS
STILL HERE WITH US TONIGHT IN
THE EXAMPLE HE SHOWED US AND THE
IDEAS HE EXPLORED AND EXPRESSED
SO BEAUTIFULLY.
LOOK UP.
IN THOSE TWO WORDS, HE SUMMED UP
HOW SCIENTISTS CAN MAKE
DISCOVERIES AND HOW ALL OF US
CAN LIVE DEEPER AND MORE
MEANINGFUL LIVES.
WE CAN'T ALL BE STEPHEN HAWKING,
BUT WE CAN ALL BE CURIOUS.
TONIGHT WE WILL MEET A GROUP OF
WOMEN AND MEN WHO ARE ALL LIVING
THAT MAXIM IN DIFFERENT WAYS, BY
LITERALLY LOOKING UP, SCANNING
THE HEAVENS TO FIND A NEW KIND
OF STAR, BY GAZING INTO THE LAWS
OF NATURE OR THE INFINITE SPACES
OF PURE MATHEMATICS AND BY
LOOKING INWARDS TO THE UNIVERSE
WITHIN.
EXACTLY 300 YEARS TO THE DAY
BEFORE STEPHEN HAWKING WAS BORN,
GALILEO DIED.
BY LOOKING UP, RAISING HIS
HOMEMADE TELESCOPE TO THE SKIES,
GALILEO LAUNCHED THE GREAT
ADVENTURE OF SCIENCE THAT HAS
BROUGHT US HERE.
LATER SOME BRIGHT SPOTS TURNED
THEIR INSTRUMENTS THE OTHER WAY,
TO OUR TRILLIONS OF CELLS, EACH
ONE A KIND OF UNIVERSE.
EVENTUALLY THEY HIT A WALL
BEYOND WHICH THEY COULD SEE NO
DEEPER.
GREAT SCIENTISTS LIKE STEPHEN
HAWKING DO NOT BELIEVE IN
BOUNDARIES.
IN INGENUITY THEY BREAK THROUGH.
OUR FIRST LAUREATE TONIGHT FOUND
A WAY TO LOOK PAST THAT WALL AND
REVEAL THE STRUCTURES OF LIFE IN
SPELL BINDING DETAIL.
PLEASE WELCOME MARK ZUCKERBERG
AND LUPITA NONGO.
>> MYSTERY IS THE SOURCE OF ALL
TRUE ART AND SCIENCE.
IT EVOKES CURIOSITY, WHICH LEADS
BOTH ARTISTS AND SCIENTISTS TO
INVESTIGATE AND INNOVATE.
MYSTERY IS WHY WE LOOK CLOSER,
DEEPER, LONGER AT THINGS TO HELP
US UNCOVER, UNDERSTAND AND
IMPROVE OURSELVES AND OUR WORLD.
>> STEPHEN HAWKING CALLED FOR US
ALL TO LOOK UP AT THE STARS AND
NOT DOWN AT YOUR FEET.
AND THAT IS WHAT ART AND SCIENCE
SHARE, THE ABILITY TO INSPIRE
AND ELEVATE ALL OF US.
TONIGHT'S HONOREES CHALLENGE US
TO LOOK UP, NOT JUST TO REAL OUR
FULL POTENTIAL, BUT TO LOOK
TOWARDS OUR CHILDREN AND THE
NEXT GENERATION OF RESEARCHERS
WHO WILL CARRY US FORWARD.
>> THROUGH THE POWER OF
CURIOSITY, THESE MATHEMATICIANS,
PHYSICISTS AND LIFE SCIENTISTS
ARE SEEKING ANSWERS TO
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
UNIVERSE.
TONIGHT'S FIRST BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IN LIFE SCIENCES GOES TO
ONE SUCH LEADING SCIENTIST, WHO
IS LOOKING TO BE THE INNERMOST
REACHES OF OURSELVES.
>> THEY HAVE DISCOVERED
PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN STRUCTURES
THAT MAKE UP THE BUILDING BLOCKS
OF OUR BODY.
LET'S TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT SOME
OF HER WORK.
♪♪
>> I THINK IT'S VERY HARD TO
LABEL ME.
AM I A PHYSICIST?
AM I A BIOLOGIST?
WHO AM I?
I DID MY WHOLE COLLEGE TRAINING
IN PHYSICS.
AND THEN WHEN I STARTED AT
STANFORD, I WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING NEW, SO THEN I JUST
GOT INTO BIOLOGY.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THE
FUNDAMENTALS.
I HAD TO ASK MY COLLEAGUES
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DNA AND RNA?
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN
UNDERSTANDING THE MOLECULAR
BASIS OF LIFE.
IN BIOLOGY, THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE SO HARD TO
ANSWER BECAUSE TOOLS ARE
MISSING, LIKE HOW THINGS GO
WRONG IN DISEASE, HOW DO THE
IMMUNE CELLS INTERACT WITH TUMOR
CELLS?
THERE ARE MANY MANY MANY MANY
DIFFERENT MOLECULES.
NOW, THESE MOLECULES ARE REALLY
TINY, THEY'RE A FEW NANO METERS
IN SIZE.
IF YOU WANT TO VISUALIZE HOW
THEY INTERACT AND FUNCTION, YOU
NEED TREMENDOUS RESOLVE AND
POWER.
IF YOU USE CONVENTIONAL LIGHT
MICROSCOY TO LOOK -- THAT WAS
THE MOTIVATION TO INVENT THIS
SUPER RESOLUTION IMAGING TOOL OF
SO THIS IS AN IMAGE OF TWO
STRUCTURES INSIDE THE CELL.
IF WE DIDN'T DO THE STORM IN THE
SAME FIELD OF VIEW, THAT WAS THE
CONVENTIONAL IMAGE.
THIS IS OUR STORM IMAGE.
THEN IF YOU DO THE CONTRAST, YOU
CAN SEE HOW SHARP IT IS.
YOU CAN SEE THESE KIND OF THINGS
THAT ARE MOLECULARLY STRIKING,
FUNCTIONALLY IMPORTANT.
EVENTUALLY WE COULD VISUALIZE
WHAT'S IN OUR BODY AT THE
MOLECULAR LEVEL JUST LIKE
WATCHING A MOVIE.
THE TOOLS THAT WE INVENTED ALL
REALLY BENEFIT SOCIETY AND
REALLY IS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR DISCOVERING HIDDEN
STRUCTURES IN CELLS THROUGH
DEVELOPMENT OF SUPER RESOLUTION
IMAGING, TRANSCENDING THE
RESOLUTION LIMITS OF LIGHT
MICROSCOPY.
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
LIFE SCIENCES IS AWARDED TO --
>> AT AGE 6 SHE IMPRESSED HER
PHYSICIST FATHER.
>> WOW.
I HAVE TO SAY AS A PROFESSOR AT
HARVARD, IT FEELS REALLY SPECIAL
TO RECEIVE THIS PRIZE.
WHAT AN EXTRAORDINARY
CELEBRATION OF SCIENCE.
I HAVE LOVED SCIENCE SINCE I WAS
A SCHOOL KID, AMAZED BY THE
SIMPLE AND ELEGANT PHYSICS LAWS
THAT EXPLAINED THE UNIVERSE.
AS I GREW OLDER, I GOT MORE AND
MORE ATTRACTED BY THE UNSOLVED
MYSTERIES IN LIFE SCIENCES.
INFLUENCED BY MY POST DOCTORAL
ADVISOR STEVEN CHU, ALSO IN THE
AUDIENCE.
SO I DECIDED TO MERGE THESE
INTERESTS AND DEVOTE MY RESEARCH
TO SOLVING BIOLOGICAL PROBLEMS
USING MULTIDISCIPLINARY
APPROACHES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THIS
TREMENDOUS HONOR WITH ALL MY
MENTORS, MENTEES AND
COLLABORATORS FOR A WONDERFUL
JOURNEY TOGETHER, THANK YOU.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> NEXT, WE HONOR THE TEAM THAT
DISCOVERED A NEW MATERIAL THAT
COULD CHANGE ELECTRONICS AND
COMPUTING FOREVER WHEN THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE RETURNS ON
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> DURING MY DECADE AS AN
ENGLISH SPY, I FELL INTO A LOT
OF THINGS, HYDROELECTRIC DAMS,
ICE PALACES, DANGEROUS LOVE
AFFAIRS, BUT EVEN MY WORST
NEMESIS NEVER CHUCKED ME INTO A
BLACK HOLE.
BUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THEY
DID?
SOME OF THE DEEPEST WORK ON THIS
QUESTION WAS DONE BY ANOTHER
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE LAUREATE, THE
ONE WHO PASSED AWAY THIS YEAR.
WINNER OF THE 2017 BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IN FUNDAMENTAL PHYSICS WAS
AMONG THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
PHYSICISTS OF HIS GENERATION.
HE DID CRITICAL WORK IN QUANTUM
THEORY, WAS A PIONEER OF SUPER
STRING THEORY AND CONTRIBUTES
BRILLIANT IDEAS ON THE BLACK
HOLE PARADOX.
HE IS GREATLY MISSED BY ALL HIS
COLLEAGUES AND HIS FAMILY WHO
ARE WITH US TONIGHT.
BUT HIS IDEAS ARE STILL ALIVE
AND COULD YET LIGHT THE PATH TO
THE NEXT BIG BREAK THROUGH AND
HOPEFULLY BREAKTHROUGHS IN THE
LABS OF SOME OF OUR LIFE SCIENCE
LAUREATES AROUND THE WORLD WHO
WILL ONE DAY CONQUER THE BRAIN
CANCER THAT TOOK HIM FROM US.
THE THRILLING ADVENTURE OF
PHYSICS CONTINUES ON THE
SHOULDERS OF GIANTS LIKE JOE AND
STEPHEN HAWKING.
TO PRESENT THIS YEAR'S AWARD,
PLEASE WELCOME AUTHOR, EDUCATOR
AND PROUD DAUGHTER LUCY HAWKING,
JOINED BY ONE OF THE FOUNDERS OF
THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE, SERGEI
BRIN.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IN LIFE, THERE WAS NOTHING MY
FATHER LIKED MORE THAN BEING THE
CENTER OF ATTENTION.
SO HE WOULD BE DELIGHTED BY THIS
EVENING'S TRIBUTE.
FOR HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO
MISS HIM SO MUCH, IIS SUCH A
JOY TO HAVE HIS EXTRAORDINARY
CONTRIBUTION CELEBRATED TONIGHT.
WHAT A PLACE FOR IT.
NASA AIMS, THIS AMAZING CENTER
OF RESEARCH IN SCIENCE AND
AVIATION, NOW CELEBRATING ITS
80th ANNIVERSARY.
THEY WERE DOING ADVANCED
INNOVATION IN TECH HERE LONG
BEFORE SILICON VALLEY BECAME THE
CENTER OF THE UNIVERSE.
>> CONDENSED MATTER PHYSICS IS
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT.
IT'S LARGELY BECAUSE OF THE
ALMOST INCONCEIVABLE NUMBER OF
STATES THAT BULK MATTER COULD BE
IN SIMULTANEOUSLY.
IT TOOK NEARLY 50 YEARS FROM THE
DISCOVERY OF SUPER CONDUCTIVITY
UNTIL IT WAS UNDERSTOOD
MATHEMATICALLY.
AND HIGH TEMPERATURE SUPER
CONDUCTORS STILL ARE NOT
UNDERSTOOD MATHEMATICALLY.
OUR NEXT LAUREATE MATHEMATICALLY
DESCRIBED AND PREDICTED A NEW
CLASS OF MATERIALS A COUPLE OF
YEARS BEFORE THEY WERE
PHYSICALLY OBSERVED.
THESE MATERIALS ARE CALLED
TOPOLOGICAL INSULATORS.
THEY'RE AMAZING NOT ONLY BECAUSE
THEIR SURFACE IS A CONDUCTOR
WHILE THE INTERIOR IS AN
INSULATOR, BUT BECAUSE OF HOW
ROBUST THEY ARE TO BROAD SWATHS
OF PRESERVATIONS.
>> THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO OF
US.
I TEND TO BE A LITTLE MORE
DRIVEN BY ABSTRACT, THEORETICAL
IDEAS.
GENE TENDS TO BE A LITTLE MORE
GROUNDED.
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY A VERY TRUE
STATEMENT.
>> A FRACTION OF MY WORK TAKE
S
A CUE FROM EXPERIMENT.
WITH THE DISCOVERY OF
TOPOLOGICAL INSULATORS, THEY
HAVE THIS VERY SPECIAL KIND OF
ELECTRICAL CONDUCTOR.
>> DOESN'T CONDUCT ELECTRICITY
ON THE INSIDE BUT ON THE
BOUNDARY, ON THE EDGE, IT DOES
CONDUCT ELECTRICITY.
IT'S LIKE A ONE-WAY STREET FOR
THE ELECTRONS.
>> SO I POSED MYSELF A THOUGHT
EXPERIMENT.
IF I WAS AN ELECTRON RIDING
ALONG THIS EDGE AND I APPROACH A
REGION WHERE THERE'S SOME DIRT
AND DISORDER, WHAT COULD HAPPEN?
YOU COULD DO THROUGH IT OR YOU
COULD BOUNCE BACK.
WHAT I REALIZED IS THERE'S A
VERY SPECIAL SYMMETRY WHICH
MAKES IT SO THAT THE PROBABILITY
FOR BOUNCING BACKWARDS IS ZERO.
>> GENERALLY THERE'S TWO KINDS
OF APPLICATIONS WHEN YOU HAVE A
NEW MATERIAL LIKE THIS.
ONE IS TRYING TO SUBSTITUTE THEM
INTO KNOWN ARCHITECTURES AND
MAKE THEM WORK BETTER.
THE REAL PAYOFF IS YOU MIGHT
BUILD THINGS THAT DON'T FOLLOW
THE ESTABLISHED ARCHITECTURES.
THERE'S TOPOLOGICAL MECHANICS
WHERE YOU TAKE STRUCTURES AND
MAKE THEM BEHAVE IN WEIRD WAYS.
>> ONE IDEA THAT WOULD BE A GAME
CHANGER IS MAKING A QUANTUM
COMPUTER.
>> IF YOU DO MAKE A QUANTUM
COMPUTER, THAT IS NOT A MARGINAL
CHANGE.
>> THERE'S A NEW FRAMEWORK THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO APPROACH A WHOLE
NEW SET OF PROBLEMS.
>> ALL THESE MATERIALS ARE
WAITING AROUND IN PLAIN SIGHT.
PEOPLE DIDN'T KNOW THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS TO ASK.
>> IT WAS LIKE A TREASURE
WAITING ON THE UNCOVERED.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR NEW IDEAS LEADING TO THE
PREDICTION OF A NEW CLASS OF
MATERIALS THAT CONDUCT
ELECTRICITY ONLY ON THEIR
SURFACE --
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
FUNDAMENTAL PHYSICS IS AWARDED
TO CHARLES CANE AND EUGENE
MULET.
>> CHARLES CANE GREW UP IN IOWA
CITY.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
ELECTRONS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> ELECTRONIC MATERIALS CAN DO
THE MOST AMAZING THINGS.
THEY'RE A FOUNDATION FOR
TECHNOLOGY, BUT THEY'RE ALSO A
WINDOW INTO THE FUNDAMENTAL WAYS
THAT MATTER CAN ARRANGE ITSELF.
>> IT'S BEEN MY GREATEST HONOR
TO PLAY A PART IN UNDERSTANDING
AND PREDICTING SOME OF THAT, BUT
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS OF A BROADER
COMMUNITY OF SCIENTISTS THAT
MADE THESE NEW GENERATIONS OF
ELECTRONIC MATERIALS COME TO
LIFE.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SO FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE MY COLLEAGUES AND
COLLABORATORS WHOSE OUTSTANDING
WORK OVER THE LAST 13 YEARS HAVE
REALLY LED TO THE RAPID
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS FIELD.
IT'S BEEN REALLY REMARKABLE.
I'M ALSO VERY PROUD THAT OUR OWN
WORK WAS CARRIED OUT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS IS AN INSTITUTION THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BY BENJAMIN FRANKLIN
FOR, IN HIS WORDS, THE PURSUIT
OF THOSE THINGS THAT ARE LIKELY
TO BE MOST USEFUL AND MOST
ORNAMENTAL AND THAT IS EXACTLY
THE IDEA BEHIND THIS SUBJECT.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> WHAT MAKES TUMORS TURN
AGGRESSIVE?
IF WE KNEW, WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
STOP THEM.
OUR NEXT LAUREATE'S BREAKTHROUGH
COULD HELP ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
UP NEXT, LIVE ON NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE, THE ONLY
AWARDS CEREMONY IN THE KNOWN
UNIVERSE THAT ACTUALLY MAKES YOU
MORE INTELLIGENT.
FOR OUR NEXT LAUREATE, JOINED BY
A BRILLIANT DIRECTOR WHOSE
VISIONS RANGE FROM A GALAXY FAR,
FAR AWAY TO THE BEAUTIFUL MIND
OF A MATHEMATICIAN RIGHT HERE ON
EARTH.
♪♪
>>> PLEASE WELCOME RON HOWARD
AND SUSAN WOJISKI.
♪♪
>> AS A MAJOR PROPONENT OF
STORY-TELLERS, INCLUDING ALL
TYPES LIKE THIS PROLIFIC ONE
STANDING RIGHT HERE NEXT TO ME,
I'M HERE TO HONOR LAUREATES WHO
ARE FINDING WAYS TO IMPROVE AND
EXTEND LIFE STORIES.
WAY BACK IN THE 20th CENTURY,
GAZING DOWN AT HIS MICROSCOPE,
HE SAW SOME LITTLE BUNDLES
CALLED CHROMOSOMES, THE GREAT
PHYSICIST IRWIN SHRODINGER.
>> IN MY DAY JOB, SOMETIMES
SCRIPT AND DEVELOPMENT ISSUES
FEEL LIKE THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS ON EARTH.
YET I'M HERE TONIGHT WITH SUSAN
IN ABSOLUTE AWE OF OUR NEXT TWO
LAUREATES, WHO ARE FIGURING OUT
THE GENETIC SCRIPT ISSUES THAT
CAN HARM OUR DEVELOPMENT.
♪♪
>> PERSISTENCE IS EVERYTHING.
THAT'S MY MOTTO IN LIFE.
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING I'M
TRYING TO INSTILL INTO MY
CHILDREN.
THE BEST THING I'VE EVER DONE, I
HAVE TO SAY, HAVING THOSE TWO
CHILDREN.
THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF BIOLOGY,
RIGHT?
YOU WANT TO PASS ON YOUR GENES.
THE WAY NATURE WORKS IS
UNMATCHED.
AND THE WAY OURSELVES WORK, THE
WAY OUR BODIES WORK, THEY WORK
JUST PERFECTLY.
NO ENGINEER COULD DESIGN
SOMETHING AS ELEGANTLY AND AS
THOUGHTFUL.
UNDERSTANDS HOW BIOLOGY WORKS
GETS US CLOSE TO THE ESSENCE OF
WHO WE ARE.
ALL OF US HAVE 46 CHROMOSOMES IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR CELLS.
23 PAIRS OF EACH.
TWO OF EACH, 46 TOTAL.
THOSE CHROMOSOMES TELL YOU WHO
YOU ARE, HOW LONG YOU'RE GOING
TO LIVE, WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
DO.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
HAVE 46 CHROMOSOMES, NOT MORE
AND NOT LESS.
THE WRONG CHROMOSOME NUMBER, A
HALLMARK OF CANCER IS THEY HAVE
THE WRONG CHROMOSOME NUMBER.
THAT MESSES EVERYTHING UP.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING, BECAUSE YOU
CHANGE THE NUMBER OF
CHROMOSOMES, YOU CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF COPIES OF GENES THAT
CELL HAS AND IT USUALLY AFFECTS
CELLS IN A BAD WAY.
I THINK OUR WORK HAS LED TO A
NUMBER OF IMPORTANT INSIGHTS AND
LED US CLOSER TO AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW GAINING OR
LOSING CHROMOSOMES CAUSES BIRTH
DEFECTS OR CAUSES CANCER.
♪♪
>> YOU CAN NOT REALLY EXPLAIN
THESE EUREKA MOMENTS AND HOW
THEY AFFECT YOU.
THAT'S LIKE THE BEST FEELING
EVER, RIGHT?
I KIND OF FEEL SAD FOR
NONSCIENCES WHO DON'T HAVE THAT
HAPPEN TO THEM VERY FREQUENTLY
IN THEIR LIVES.
JUST THAT OH MY GOD, I GET IT
FEELING.
THAT'S THE BEST.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> SO FOR TERMING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ABNORMAL
CHROMOSOME NUMBER RESULTING FROM
THE MISSEGREGATION OF
CHROMOSOMES --
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
LIFE SENSES IS AWARDED TO
ANGELIKA AMON.
>> AN IDEA HAS TO BE EASILY
EXPLAINABLE TO PIQUE HER
INTEREST.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> MAKING A DISCOVERY IS THE
BEST FEELING IN THE WORLD.
IT'S LIKE CHRISTMAS WHEN YOU
WERE 5.
THE BEAUTY --
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THE BEAUTY OF EXPERIMENTAL
SCIENCES THAT THESE EUREKA
MOMENTS ARE OFTEN SHARED WITH
OTHER SCIENTISTS.
I'M PRIVILEGED TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS.
I THEREFORE SHARE THIS
TREMENDOUS HONOR WITH THE MANY
WONDERFUL STUDENTS AND POST DOCS
THAT I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE
WORKED WITH AND MY FAMILY, WHO
SUPPORTED ME IN MY ENDEAVOR TO
SEEK THE TRUTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THIS EVENING AT THE
♪♪
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE WE'RE
>> THIS EVENING AT THE
FOLLOWING STEPHEN HAWKING'S
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE WE'RE
ADVICE TO LOOK UP.
FOLLOWING STEPHEN HAWKING'S
SOMETIMES THAT MEANS LOOKING UP
ADVICE TO LOOK UP.
TO A HERO AND DISCOVERING YOUR
SOMETIMES THAT MEANS LOOKING UP
OWN TALENT.
TO A HERO AND DISCOVERING YOUR
FOR ME, IT WAS THE GREAT
OWN TALENT.
PLAYWRIGHT TENNESSEE WILLIAMS,
FOR ME, IT WAS THE GREAT
WHO CAST ME IN ONE OF HIS PLAYS
PLAYWRIGHT TENNESSEE WILLIAMS,
WHEN I WAS 21 AND CHANGED MY
WHO CAST ME IN ONE OF HIS PLAYS
CAREER.
WHEN I WAS 21 AND CHANGED MY
THE 16-YEAR-OLD YOU'RE ABOUT TO
CAREER.
MEET, THOSE HEROS ARE GREAT
THE 16-YEAR-OLD YOU'RE ABOUT TO
SCIENTISTS, LIKE THE ONES WE'RE
MEET, THOSE HEROS ARE GREAT
CELEBRATING TONIGHT.
SCIENTISTS, LIKE THE ONES WE'RE
TO INTRODUCE US TO AN
CELEBRATING TONIGHT.
EXTRAORDINARY TALENT, PLEASE
TO INTRODUCE US TO AN
WELCOME A YOUNG CHINESE MUSICAL
EXTRAORDINARY TALENT, PLEASE
SENSATION, WHOSE SONGS HAVE
WELCOME A YOUNG CHINESE MUSICAL
AMASSED NEARLY 10 BILLION VIEWS,
SENSATION, WHOSE SONGS HAVE
GEM, JOINED BY ONE OF THE
AMASSED NEARLY 10 BILLION VIEWS,
FOUNDERS OF THE BREAKTHROUGH
GEM, JOINED BY ONE OF THE
PRIZE, JULIA MILLNER.
FOUNDERS OF THE BREAKTHROUGH
♪♪
PRIZE, JULIA MILLNER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> WHEN I WAS 13, I STARTED
[ APPLAUSE ]
WRITING MY OWN SONGS.
>> WHEN I WAS 13, I STARTED
I DISCOVERED A DEEP SATISFACTION
WRITING MY OWN SONGS.
OF CREATING SOMETHING NEW.
I DISCOVERED A DEEP SATISFACTION
BUT FIRST I HAD TO IMMERSE
OF CREATING SOMETHING NEW.
MYSELF IN MUSICAL TRADITIONS
BUT FIRST I HAD TO IMMERSE
THAT CAME BEFORE ME.
MYSELF IN MUSICAL TRADITIONS
SCIENCE, LIKE THE ARTS, NEEDS
THAT CAME BEFORE ME.
FRESH IDEAS, BUT TO BREAK
SCIENCE, LIKE THE ARTS, NEEDS
THROUGH TO SOMETHING NEW, YOU
FRESH IDEAS, BUT TO BREAK
HAVE TO ABSORB WHAT IS ALREADY
THROUGH TO SOMETHING NEW, YOU
KNOWN.
HAVE TO ABSORB WHAT IS ALREADY
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR
KNOWN.
CHALLENGE IS A GLOBAL
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR
COMPETITION THAT INSPIRES YOUNG
CHALLENGE IS A GLOBAL
PEOPLE TO EXPLORE SCIENTIFIC
COMPETITION THAT INSPIRES YOUNG
IDEAS AND SPREAD THEIR
PEOPLE TO EXPLORE SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE.
IDEAS AND SPREAD THEIR
TO SOLVE THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS,
KNOWLEDGE.
WE NEED THE NEXT GENERATION TO
TO SOLVE THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS,
BE INSPIRED BY SCIENCE.
WE NEED THE NEXT GENERATION TO
BUT GREAT SCIENTISTS LIKE
BE INSPIRED BY SCIENCE.
ARTISTS NEED MORE THAN JUST
BUT GREAT SCIENTISTS LIKE
INSPIRATION.
ARTISTS NEED MORE THAN JUST
THEY ALSO NEED PERSISTENCE.
INSPIRATION.
THIS YEAR HE TRIED AGAIN AND
THEY ALSO NEED PERSISTENCE.
WENT ONE BETTER.
THIS YEAR HE TRIED AGAIN AND
♪♪
WENT ONE BETTER.
>> WHAT I SEE IN HIM IS HIS
♪♪
ABILITY TO CONVERT WHAT HE'S
>> WHAT I SEE IN HIM IS HIS
LEARNING CURRENTLY INTO
ABILITY TO CONVERT WHAT HE'S
SOMETHING BIGGER, SOMETHING THAT
LEARNING CURRENTLY INTO
BENEFITS SOCIETY.
SOMETHING BIGGER, SOMETHING THAT
I'M VERY EXCITED TO SEE THAT
BENEFITS SOCIETY.
LOOK ON HIS FACE WHEN HE FINDS
I'M VERY EXCITED TO SEE THAT
OUT HE HAS ACTUALLY WON THE
LOOK ON HIS FACE WHEN HE FINDS
BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR CHALLENGE
OUT HE HAS ACTUALLY WON THE
2018.
BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR CHALLENGE
>> YES!
2018.
♪♪
>> YES!
>> OH MY GOSH.
♪♪
>> IT'S JUST SURREAL THAT THIS
>> OH MY GOSH.
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
>> IT'S JUST SURREAL THAT THIS
MY MIND IS JUST BLOWN AND I'M
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
JUST VERY, VERY, VERY HAPPY.
MY MIND IS JUST BLOWN AND I'M
>> A BREAKTHROUGH THAT HAS A FAR
JUST VERY, VERY, VERY HAPPY.
REACHING IMPACT.
>> A BREAKTHROUGH THAT HAS A FAR
WELCOME TO THE MAGIC OF
REACHING IMPACT.
CIRCADIAN RHYTHM, OUR BODY
WELCOME TO THE MAGIC OF
CLOCKS.
CIRCADIAN RHYTHM, OUR BODY
THEY DICTATE THE BEST TIME FOR
CLOCKS.
ANY ACTIVITY.
THEY DICTATE THE BEST TIME FOR
MY TOPICS ARE GENERALLY INSPIRED
ANY ACTIVITY.
BY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
MY TOPICS ARE GENERALLY INSPIRED
ONE OF MY FAMILY MEMBERS SUFFERS
BY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
FROM PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
ONE OF MY FAMILY MEMBERS SUFFERS
I'VE ALSO HAD A FEW SEVERE
ASTHMA ATTACKS.
I NOTICED THAT THESE ATTACKS
SEEM TO PEAK EARLY IN THE
MORNING AND I SAW THE
CORRELATION WITH THE CIRCADIAN
RHYTHM.
THIS IS MY SCHOOL AND THIS IS
WHERE THE NEW BREAKTHROUGH
SCIENCE LAB WILL BE BUILT.
>> IT WILL BE WONDERFUL TO GIVE
THEM A LAB ON WHICH THEY CAN TRY
OUT THEIR IDEAS, BECAUSE WE
NEVER KNOW WHERE THE NEXT
BREAKTHROUGH COMES FROM.
>> ANOTHER THING THE
BREAKTHROUGH CHALLENGE OPENED ME
UP TO WAS THE POWER OF SCIENCE
THROUGH STORY-TELLING.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE A PART OF
WORKING ON THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
THROUGH A FUSION OF TECHNOLOGY
AND ENTERTAINMENT.
I REALLY WANT TO MAKE SCIENCE
FUN FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU FOR WATCHING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR HIS VIDEO, CIRCADIAN
RHYTHMS, THE WINNER OF THE 2018
BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR CHALLENGE.
>> WHAT AN HONOR FOR ME TO BE
HERE.
FOR ME, SCIENCE IS ABOUT
UNRAVELING THE MOST COMPLEX
MACHINE IN THE UNIVERSE, OUR
BODIES.
FROM CURING DISEASES TO
IMPROVING QUALITY OF LIFE, THESE
ARE THE ADVENTURES I WANT TO BE
A PART OF.
STEPHEN HAWKING SAID IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
KEEP THEIR SENSE OF WONDER AND
KEEP ASKING WHY.
THE BREAKTHROUGH JUNIOR
CHALLENGE ALLOWS US TO DO THAT,
OPENING DOORS TO THE WORLD OF
PURE SCIENCES, FREEING US TO
LEARN WITH AN OPEN MIND.
THANKS TO MY TEACHERS AND FAMILY
FOR THEIR GUIDANCE.
MY SISTER THEA WHO KEEPS
LECTURING ME, I HOPE I DID OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>>> GRAMMY WINNING SUPERSTAR
LIONEL RICHIE WILL PERFORM ONE
OF HIS GREATEST HITS WHEN THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE CONTINUES.
♪♪
>>> I'M THRILLED TO INTRODUCE
ONE OF THE BEST-SELLING MUSIC
ARTISTS ON EARTH AND PERHAPS
BEYOND TOO.
BECAUSE HE'S AN AMERICAN, THIS
MUSICAL GIANT HAS NOT YET BEEN
KNIGHTED, THOUGH I DO RECALL HE
WAS A COMMODORE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE ONE
AND ONLY LIONEL RICHIE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT FOR ALWAYS ♪
♪ THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE ♪
♪ SAY, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT TOGETHER, NATURALLY ♪
♪ I HAD A DREAM, I HAD AN
AWESOME DREAM ♪
♪ PEOPLE IN THE PARK, PLAYING
GAMES IN THE GARDEN ♪
♪ AND WHAT THEY PLAYED WAS A
MASQUERADE ♪
♪ FROM BEHIND THE WALLS OF
DOUBT, I HEARD VOICES CRYING
OUT ♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT FOR ALWAYS ♪
♪ THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE ♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT TOGETHER, NATURALLY ♪
♪ AS WE GO DOWN LIFE'S LONESOME
HIGHWAY, SEEMS THE HARDEST THING
TO DO IS TO FIND A FRIEND OR
TWO ♪
♪ THAT HELPING HAND, SOMEONE WHO
UNDERSTANDS, WHEN YOU FEEL
YOU'VE LOST YOUR WAY ♪
♪ THERE'S SOMEONE THERE TO SAY
AND SHOW YOU, OH YEAH ♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT FOR ALWAYS ♪
♪ THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE ♪
♪ EVERYBODY, SING TOGETHER RIGHT
HERE ♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT TOGETHER, NATURALLY ♪
♪ SO YOU THINK YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER, WHOA NO ♪
♪ WHEN THE WHOLE WORLD'S GOT YOU
DANCING, I'M TELLING YOU ♪
♪ BELIEVE IN WHO YOU ARE, YOU
ARE A SHINING STAR ♪
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
♪ SAY IT FOR ALWAYS ♪
♪ THAT'S THE WAY IT SHOULD BE ♪
>> ONE MORE TIME ALL TOGETHER
SING!
♪ SAY YOU, SAY ME ♪
>> SOUNDING GOOD, YOU GUYS!
♪ SAY IT TOGETHER, NATURALLY ♪
♪ SAY IT TOGETHER, YEAH ♪
♪ OH YEAH ♪
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YEAH!
♪♪
>>> COMING UP, WE HONOR A
BIOLOGIST WHO DISCOVERED HOW
CELLS DETECT INVADERS.
AND EDDIE REDMAYNE PAYS TRIBUTE
TO STEPHEN HAWKING ON THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE.
>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE
AND NOW PLEASE WELCOME BACK LUCY
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE.
HAWKING.
AND NOW PLEASE WELCOME BACK LUCY
♪♪
HAWKING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> MY FATHER'S LIFE WAS
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEDICATED TO FINDING ANSWERS TO
>> MY FATHER'S LIFE WAS
THE BIGGEST QUESTIONS.
DEDICATED TO FINDING ANSWERS TO
HE WAS FASCINATED NOT JUST BY
THE BIGGEST QUESTIONS.
THE UNIVERSE, BUT BY LIFE.
HE WAS FASCINATED NOT JUST BY
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
THE UNIVERSE, BUT BY LIFE.
ARE WE ALONE?
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
WHAT IS OUR FATE IN THE COSMOS?
ARE WE ALONE?
I'M VERY PLEASED TO WELCOME A
WHAT IS OUR FATE IN THE COSMOS?
GREAT FRIEND OF MY FATHER'S AND
I'M VERY PLEASED TO WELCOME A
HIS COLLABORATOR IN EXPLORING,
GREAT FRIEND OF MY FATHER'S AND
YURI MELNER.
HIS COLLABORATOR IN EXPLORING,
[ APPLAUSE ]
YURI MELNER.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THE FIRST TIME I SAW STEPHEN
♪♪
HAWKING WAS AT THE PHYSICS
>> THE FIRST TIME I SAW STEPHEN
CONFERENCE IN 1987 AND HE
HAWKING WAS AT THE PHYSICS
INSTANTLY BECAME MY HERO.
CONFERENCE IN 1987 AND HE
HIS WORK ON BLACK HOLES IMPLIED
INSTANTLY BECAME MY HERO.
SOMETHING SHOCKING, THAT
HIS WORK ON BLACK HOLES IMPLIED
INFORMATION FALLING INTO ONE IS
SOMETHING SHOCKING, THAT
LOST FOREVER.
INFORMATION FALLING INTO ONE IS
IT'S LIKE LOSING YOUR CELL
LOST FOREVER.
PHONE.
IT'S LIKE LOSING YOUR CELL
I NEVER FORGOT THE IMPRESSION HE
PHONE.
MADE ON ME THAT DAY.
I NEVER FORGOT THE IMPRESSION HE
HIS WORDS CAME THROUGH THE
MADE ON ME THAT DAY.
INTERPRETER, BUT HIS CHARACTER
HIS WORDS CAME THROUGH THE
CAME THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR, HIS
INTERPRETER, BUT HIS CHARACTER
COURAGE, HIS CURIOSITY AND HIS
CAME THROUGH LOUD AND CLEAR, HIS
HONESTY.
COURAGE, HIS CURIOSITY AND HIS
LATER IT WAS THAT CHARACTERISIC
HONESTY.
HONESTY THAT HE DECIDED THAT HIS
LATER IT WAS THAT CHARACTERISIC
INITIAL CONCLUSION WAS WRONG.
HONESTY THAT HE DECIDED THAT HIS
THE INFORMATION IN THE BLACK
INITIAL CONCLUSION WAS WRONG.
HOLE SURVIVED AND THE UNIVERSE
THE INFORMATION IN THE BLACK
DOES NOT FORGET.
HOLE SURVIVED AND THE UNIVERSE
AND NEITHER WILL WE FORGET
DOES NOT FORGET.
STEPHEN HAWKING, THE SCIENTIST
AND NEITHER WILL WE FORGET
AND THE MAN.
STEPHEN HAWKING, THE SCIENTIST
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND THE MAN.
>> I WOULD NOW LIKE TO INTRODUCE
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE ACTOR WHOSE OSCAR WINNING
>> I WOULD NOW LIKE TO INTRODUCE
PERFORMANCE OF STEPHEN HAWKING
THE ACTOR WHOSE OSCAR WINNING
REMAINS SO MEMORABLE.
PERFORMANCE OF STEPHEN HAWKING
♪♪
REMAINS SO MEMORABLE.
>> SO WHAT NEXT?
♪♪
>> PROVE IT.
>> SO WHAT NEXT?
♪♪
>> PROVE IT.
>> THE ONE SIMPLE ELEGANT
♪♪
EQUATION TO EXPLAIN EVERYTHING.
>> THE ONE SIMPLE ELEGANT
[ APPLAUSE ]
EQUATION TO EXPLAIN EVERYTHING.
>> PLEASE WELCOME EDDIE
[ APPLAUSE ]
REDMAYNE.
>> PLEASE WELCOME EDDIE
♪♪
REDMAYNE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> GOOD EVENING, LADIES AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
GENTLEMEN.
>> GOOD EVENING, LADIES AND
IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY HONOR TO
GENTLEMEN.
BE HERE WITH YOU THIS EVENING.
IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY HONOR TO
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
BE HERE WITH YOU THIS EVENING.
AND SPEND TIME WITH STEPHEN AND
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
HIS FAMILY HAS GENUINELY BEEN
AND SPEND TIME WITH STEPHEN AND
ONE OF THE GREAT, GREAT GIFTS OF
HIS FAMILY HAS GENUINELY BEEN
MY LIFE.
ONE OF THE GREAT, GREAT GIFTS OF
AS ACTORS, WE OF COURSE RELISH
MY LIFE.
PLAYING HUMAN BEINGS OF
AS ACTORS, WE OF COURSE RELISH
COMPLEXITY AND CONTRAST, BUT
PLAYING HUMAN BEINGS OF
THERE IS NO HUMAN BEING QUITE
COMPLEXITY AND CONTRAST, BUT
LIKE STEPHEN HAWKING.
THERE IS NO HUMAN BEING QUITE
HE WAS A MAN OF EXTRAORDINARY
LIKE STEPHEN HAWKING.
POWER, BUT ALSO OF DEEP
HE WAS A MAN OF EXTRAORDINARY
VULNERABILITY.
POWER, BUT ALSO OF DEEP
AND HE HAD THIS MIND THAT COULD
VULNERABILITY.
SOAR TO THE EDGE OF BLACK HOLES,
AND HE HAD THIS MIND THAT COULD
AND YET HE ALSO HAD TO SLUG IT
SOAR TO THE EDGE OF BLACK HOLES,
OUT IN A GRUELING DAILY BATTLE
AND YET HE ALSO HAD TO SLUG IT
AGAINST A CRUEL, CRUEL DISEASE.
OUT IN A GRUELING DAILY BATTLE
WHEN I FIRST MET PROFESSOR
AGAINST A CRUEL, CRUEL DISEASE.
HAWKING, THE THING THAT BLEW ME
WHEN I FIRST MET PROFESSOR
AWAY WAS THIS OTHER SIDE TO HIM,
HAWKING, THE THING THAT BLEW ME
PERHAPS NOT QUITE AS WELL KNOWN
AWAY WAS THIS OTHER SIDE TO HIM,
AS HIS BRILLIANCE AND HIS
PERHAPS NOT QUITE AS WELL KNOWN
DEFIANCE.
AS HIS BRILLIANCE AND HIS
STEPHEN WAS 1000% PURE SHOWMAN.
DEFIANCE.
HE HAD THIS GLINT IN HIS EYE,
STEPHEN WAS 1000% PURE SHOWMAN.
THIS SORT OF JAMES DEAN QUALITY
HE HAD THIS GLINT IN HIS EYE,
AND HIS SENSE OF HUMOR AND HIS
THIS SORT OF JAMES DEAN QUALITY
SENSE OF TIMING THAT HAD TO BE
AND HIS SENSE OF HUMOR AND HIS
SEEN TO BE BELIEVED.
SENSE OF TIMING THAT HAD TO BE
AND BOTH VIRTUE OF THAT
SEEN TO BE BELIEVED.
EXTRAORDINARY MIND AND THAT
AND BOTH VIRTUE OF THAT
EXTRAORDINARY WIT, HE LITERALLY
EXTRAORDINARY MIND AND THAT
HELD EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO MET
EXTRAORDINARY WIT, HE LITERALLY
HIM IN THE PALM OF HIS HAND.
HELD EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO MET
PROFESSOR HAWKING WAS A HUGE
HIM IN THE PALM OF HIS HAND.
INSPIRATION TO ME, JUST AS HE
PROFESSOR HAWKING WAS A HUGE
WAS AND REMAINS AN INSPIRATION
INSPIRATION TO ME, JUST AS HE
TO PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE WORLD,
WAS AND REMAINS AN INSPIRATION
YOUNG PEOPLE, OLDER PEOPLE,
TO PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE WORLD,
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES, PEOPLE
YOUNG PEOPLE, OLDER PEOPLE,
OF SCIENCE AND PEOPLE WHO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES, PEOPLE
FRANKLY JUST ARE CURIOUS ABOUT
OF SCIENCE AND PEOPLE WHO
OUR EXISTENCE AND WHAT THAT
FRANKLY JUST ARE CURIOUS ABOUT
COULD ALL MEAN.
OUR EXISTENCE AND WHAT THAT
SO DEAR STEPHEN, THANK YOU FOR
COULD ALL MEAN.
IT ALL, SIR.
SO DEAR STEPHEN, THANK YOU FOR
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT ALL, SIR.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> TO PRESENT OUR NEXT PRIZE,
♪♪
PLEASE WELCOME AN ACADEMY AWARD
>> TO PRESENT OUR NEXT PRIZE,
WINNING NOMINEE JOINED BY AN
PLEASE WELCOME AN ACADEMY AWARD
EXECUTIVE WHO UNDERSTANDS THAT
WINNING NOMINEE JOINED BY AN
"THE NOTEBOOK" WAS A GREAT MOVIE
EXECUTIVE WHO UNDERSTANDS THAT
BUT AN OUTDATED PIECE OF
"THE NOTEBOOK" WAS A GREAT MOVIE
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT AN OUTDATED PIECE OF
RACHEL McADAMS AND THE CEO OF
TECHNOLOGY.
PAYPAL DAN SHULMAN.
RACHEL McADAMS AND THE CEO OF
♪♪
PAYPAL DAN SHULMAN.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> IT IS SUCH AN HONOR TO BE
[ APPLAUSE ]
HERE AT MY FIRST BREAKTHROUGH
>> IT IS SUCH AN HONOR TO BE
PRIZE.
HERE AT MY FIRST BREAKTHROUGH
THIS IS AN EXTRAORDINARILY
PRIZE.
INSPIRING EVENT THAT MAKES ME
FEEL SO MUCH BETTER ABOUT THE
STATE OF THE WORLD TODAY, WHICH
IS A REAL NICE CHANGE OF PACE.
IN THE ELOQUENT WORDS OF THE
GREAT SCIENTIST MARIE CURRIE --
NOW IS THE TIME TO UNDERSTAND
NOW SO THAT WE MAY FEAR LESS.
>> OUR NOMINEE IS A BIOCHEMIST
WHOSE BREAKTHROUGH WORK IN THE
DISCOVERY OF THE DNA SENSING
ENZYME C-GAS -- THE MORE WE KNOW
ABOUT THESE FRONT LINE FIGHTERS
OF THE IMMUNE SYSTEM, THE LESS
WE HAVE TO FEAR ON MANY MEDICAL
FRONTS.
♪♪
>> I GREW UP IN A SMALL VILLAGE
IN CHINA, VERY ISOLATED
ENVIRONMENT.
WE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
WHEN I WAS 12 YEARS OLD, AT THE
TIME THERE WAS A SAYING THAT IF
YOU LEARNED MATH, PHYSICS AND
CHEMISTRY, THEN YOU CAN EXPLORE
THE WHOLE WORLD.
FOR A KID COMING FROM A SMALL
VILLAGE, THE POSSIBILITY OF
EXPLORING THE WHOLE WORLD WAS
VERY TEMPTING.
♪♪
>> DNA CAN STIMULATE IMMUNE
RESPONSES, BUT YOU NEED TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT KNOWS THE DNA IS
THERE.
WE WENT IN TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
THIS DNA SENSOR, BUT WE GOT A
LOT MORE THAN WHAT WE WERE
LOOKING FOR, THIS DNA SENSOR
THAT WE CALL C-GAS RECOGNIZES
ALL THE DNA.
IT'S NOT JUST PATHOGEN DNA, IT'S
ALSO OUR OWN DNA.
THINK OF IT LIKE A MOTION SENSOR
IN OUR HOUSE.
WHEN DNA COMES INTO OUR CELLS,
C-GAS CAN THEN TRIGGER THE
IMMUNE RESPONSE.
NOT ONLY PROVIDES THE ANSWER TO
THIS LONG-STANDING QUESTION OF
HOW OUR IMMUNE SYSTEM RECOGNIZES
DNA BUT ALSO PROVIDES THE LINK
TO MANY HUMAN PIECES.
COMPANIES PUT TOGETHER PROGRAMS
TO FIND INHIBITORS OF C-GAS AND
THERE ARE TRIALS ONGOING TO TEST
THESE COMPOUNDS.
IT IS VERY GRATIFYING TO SEE
THAT OUR DISCOVERY, WHICH
STARTED WITH CURIOSITY, HELPING
PATIES WHO SUFFER FROM CANCER,
FROM AUTO IMMUNE DISEASES, FROM
PARKINSON'S DISEASE.
ONCE YOU DISCOVER THAT, YOU KNOW
THIS IS GOING TO LAST FOR A LONG
TIME.
THAT'S THE THRILL OF MAKING A
DISCOVERY.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR DISCOVERING HOW DNA
TRIGGERS IMMUNE AND AUTO
IMMUNE --
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE IN
LIFE SCIENCES IS AWARDED TO
ZHIJIAN CHEN.
>> I THINK I'M LIVING PROOF THAT
EDUCATION IS THE GREATEST
EQUALIZER, BUT EDUCATION DID
MORE THAN LIFT ME OUT OF
POVERTY, IT ALLOWED ME TO
EXPLORE THE WORLD, THE WONDERFUL
WORLD OF SCIENCE.
IT ALLOWED ME AND MY COLLEAGUES
TO EXPLORE THE INTERIOR OF OUR
CELLS AND DISCOVER MOLECULES
THAT NO ONE HAD EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
SO FOR THIS, I WANT TO THANK
MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE HELPED AND
SUPPORTED ME ALONG THE WAY.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY TO ALL
YOUNG PEOPLE AROUND THE GLOBE,
HEY, IF I CAN IT, YOU CAN TOO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>>> NEXT, A LEGENDARY ASTRONOMER
WHO DISCOVERED MOST EXOTIC STARS
IN THE UNIVERSE WHEN SHE WAS
JUST 23 YEARS OLD.
WHEN THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE
CONTINUES.
>>> PLEASE WELCOME ONE OF THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE FOUNDERS,
ANN WOJUSKI AND ORLANDO BLOOM.
>> WORKING WITH DNA, I'VE SEEN
THE BEAUTIFUL COMPLEXITY THAT
MAKES EVERY ONE OF US UNIQUE.
A SINGLE ERROR CAN CAUSE SO MUCH
HARM, THOUGH.
WE LIVE IN A MOMENT WHEN FIXING
THOSE ERRORS WITH GENE THERAPIES
IS BECOMING POSSIBLE.
THAT MEANS WE LIVE IN A TIME OF
HOPE.
>> HOPE LIES IN DREAMS AND
IMAGINATION AND THE COURAGE OF
THOSE WHO DARE TO MAKE DREAMS
INTO REALITY.
THOSE WERE THE WORDS OF JONAS
SALKE WHOSE BREAKTHROUGH WORK
WITH THE POLIO VACCINE CHANGED
COUNTLESS LIVES.
♪♪
>> FEBRUARY 6th, 2013, THIS
BEAUTIFUL LITTLE GIRL CAME INTO
OUR WORLD, HEALTHY, HAPPY,
KICKING.
AROUND 13 MONTHS, ALL HELL BROKE
LOSE.
COULDN'T BARELY HOLD HER HEAD
UP.
>> ANNA LARSON IS A TYPE TWO SNA
PATIENT, SPINAL MUSCULAR
ATROPHIES.
EVENTUALLY PATIENTS GET MUSCLE
WEAKNESS AND PARALYSIS AND
RESPIRATORY FAILURE.
COULD BE VERY LIFE-THREATENING.
>> WHAT YOU THOUGHT WAS A HAPPY,
HEALTHY BABY.
NOW YOU'RE ALMOST HANDED A DEATH
SENTENCE.
>> FRANK WORKS IN BIOTECHNOLOGY
WHERE THEIR FOCUS IS ON DRUG
DEVELOPMENT.
>> AFTER LEARNING ABOUT THE
DISEASE, I THOUGHT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
ON.
>> HE CALLED ME UP ONE DAY AND
AGREED TO START COLLABORATING.
MY LAB IS INTERESTED IN RNA
SPLICING.
IT'S UNDERSTANDING THE BASIC
WORKINGS OF THE CELL AND HOW
GENES FUNCTION.
OUR INITIAL COLLABORATION WAS
HOW TO USE ANTI-SENSE TECHNOLOGY
TO MODULATE SPLICING IN WAYS
THAT MIGHT HAVE THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS.
WITHIN SOME TIME AFTER THAT, WE
BEGAN TO FOCUS ON SPINAL
MUSCULAR ATROPHY.
>> WE WERE DOING WORK TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW TO DELIVER THE
DRUG.
>> OH MY GOODNESS, LOOK AT YOU!
BIG GIRL!
>> OUR TECHNOLOGY IS BASED ON
DESIGNING SMALL PIECES OF
BINDERS TO THE RNA INTERMEDIATE
MOLECULES AND MODULATE THEM.
WE'RE ALTERING THE FUNCTION OF
THE RNA SO THAT IT MAKES THE
PROTEIN WE WANT IT TO MAKE.
>> SINCE SHE'S GOTTEN THAT FIRST
INJECTION, SHE'S GOTTEN STRONGER
AND HAD THE DISEASE STOPPED.
>> WE'RE NOT JUST STABILIZING
THE DISEASE, BUT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY IMPROVING.
>> THIS IS MY FIRST EXPERIENCE
WHERE I'VE WORKED ON A DRUG THAT
HAD THIS BIG OF AN IMPACT ON A
PATIENT.
IT STILL BRINGS TEARS TO MY
EYES.
IT'S A MIRACLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> IN THE FILM, YOU JUST SAW A
WONDERFUL FAMILY WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN TRANSFORMED BY DR.
BENNETT AND DR. CRANER.
PLEASE WELCOME EMMA LARSON, HER
MOTHER DIANE AND HER FATHER
MATT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
>> ON JULY 22nd, 2014, OUR
DAUGHTER WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
SPINAL MUSCULAR ATROPHY.
SMA IS THE NUMBER ONE GENETIC
KILLER OF INFANTS.
DOCTORS TOLD US THERE WAS NO
TREATMENT OR CURE, SO BASICALLY
WE WOULD WATCH OUR DAUGHTER
SLOWLY GET WEAKER AND DIE.
ON HER SECOND BIRTHDAY, WE
ENROLLED HER IN A TRIAL.
THERE WAS HOPE.
ON DECEMBER 23rd, 2016, THE DRUG
CREATED BY DR. KRAINOR AND DR.
BENNETT BECAME THE FIRST FDA
APPROVED TREATMENT FOR SMA.
THANK YOU BOTH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU BOTH FOR YOUR
CONTINUOUS YEARS OF RESEARCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE SLEEPLESS
NIGHTS WORKING ON THIS DRUG AND
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME SPENT
AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY TO SAVE
OURS.
WITH SCIENCE, THERE'S HOPE.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF AN
EFFECTIVE ANTI-SENSE THERAPY,
FOR CHILDREN WITH THE
DEGENERATIVE DISEASE SPINAL
MUSCULAR ATROPHY --
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRICE IN
LIFE SCIENCES IS AWARDED TO
FRANK BENNETT AND ADRIAN
KRAINER.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
♪♪
GREAT HONOR.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
WHILE WE ARE HERE TONIGHT TO
GREAT HONOR.
CELEBRATE SCIENCE, INCLUDING THE
WHILE WE ARE HERE TONIGHT TO
BASIC AND APPLIED RESEARCH THAT
CELEBRATE SCIENCE, INCLUDING THE
GAVE US AN EFFECTIVE DRUG TO
BASIC AND APPLIED RESEARCH THAT
TREAT SPINAL MUSCULAR ATROPHY,
GAVE US AN EFFECTIVE DRUG TO
LET US NOT FORGET THE TENS OF
TREAT SPINAL MUSCULAR ATROPHY,
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS AROUND THE
LET US NOT FORGET THE TENS OF
WORLD WHO DO NOT YET HAVE ACCESS
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS AROUND THE
TO THIS TREATMENT.
WORLD WHO DO NOT YET HAVE ACCESS
THIS MUST CHANGE, AND I'M
TO THIS TREATMENT.
CERTAIN IT WILL.
THIS MUST CHANGE, AND I'M
BUT FOR THESE PATIENTS, EVERY
CERTAIN IT WILL.
DAY COUNTS.
BUT FOR THESE PATIENTS, EVERY
THANK YOU.
DAY COUNTS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
>> I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
HONORED TO BE RECOGNIZED AS A
>> I'M EXTREMELY GRATEFUL AND
CORECIPIENT OF THE BREAK THROUGH
HONORED TO BE RECOGNIZED AS A
PRIZE.
CORECIPIENT OF THE BREAK THROUGH
MY WIFE PAULA DESERVES SPECIAL
PRIZE.
THANKS FOR SUPPORT FOR OVER 30
MY WIFE PAULA DESERVES SPECIAL
YEARS.
THANKS FOR SUPPORT FOR OVER 30
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
YEARS.
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES SUCH
I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AS THE LARSONS WHO HAVE
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES SUCH
PARTICIPATED IN OUR CLINICAL
AS THE LARSONS WHO HAVE
STUDIES.
PARTICIPATED IN OUR CLINICAL
THEY ARE MY SOURCE OF
STUDIES.
INSPIRATION.
THEY ARE MY SOURCE OF
DRUG DISCOVERY AND DEVELOPMENT
INSPIRATION.
IS VERY MUCH A TEAM EFFORT THAT
DRUG DISCOVERY AND DEVELOPMENT
REQUIRES A HEALTHY ECOSYSTEM OF
IS VERY MUCH A TEAM EFFORT THAT
BASIC AND CLINICAL SCIENCES,
REQUIRES A HEALTHY ECOSYSTEM OF
DRUG HUNTERS AND DEVELOPERS AND
BASIC AND CLINICAL SCIENCES,
REGULATORS TO TRANSFORM A DREAM
DRUG HUNTERS AND DEVELOPERS AND
INTO REALITY.
REGULATORS TO TRANSFORM A DREAM
THANK YOU.
INTO REALITY.
♪♪
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> SO INSPIRING TO SEE REAL
PROGRESS AGAINST NEUROLOGICAL
DISEASES.
THOSE SHADOWS THAT TOUCH SO MANY
OF OUR LIVES.
ONE OF OUR NEXT PRESENTERS WON
AN ACADEMY AWARD FOR HER
POWERFUL PORTRAYAL OF A WOMAN
SUFFERING FROM ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE IN THE 2014 FILM "STILL
ALICE."
>> I'VE ALWAYS BEEN SO DEFINED
BY MY INTELLECT, MY LANGUAGE, MY
ARTICULATION.
AND NOW SOMETIMES I CAN SEE THE
WORDS HANGING IN FRONT OF ME AND
I CAN'T REACH THEM AND I DON'T
KNOW WHO I AM AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M GOING TO LOSE NEXT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> JUNIOR COLLEGE, JULIANNE
MOORE ACCOMPANIED BY ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE, DR. PRISCILLA CHANG.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> IN 1967 JOCELYN BELL STOOD
BEFORE THE ANCIENT WALLS OF
CAMBRIDGE UNIVERSITY FEELING
LIKE AN IMPOSTER.
SHE WONDERED WHAT SHE WAS DOING
HERE AMONG ALL THESE BRILLIANT
MIND.
SHE WAS CERTAIN SHE'D BE FOUND
OUT AND SENT BACK TO NORTHERN
IRELAND IN DISGRACE.
>> SO JOCELYN MADE A PROMISE TO
HERSELF.
SHE WOULD GIVE EVERYTHING SHE
HAD TO SCIENCE, LEAVE NOTHING ON
THE FIELD AND LEAVE WITH HER
HEAD HELD HIGH.
>> SHE STARTED LITERALLY IN A
FIELD, SWINGING A 20-POUND
SLEDGE HAMMER, HELPING TO BUILD
A HUGE RADIO STETHOSCOPE.
ONCE SHE BUILT IT, SHE RAN IT.
EVERY SPARE HOUR, HUNCHED OVER
READ-OUTS SEARCHING FOR THE
SHIMMER OF DISTANT GALAXIES.
>> ONE DAY SHE SEES SOMETHING, A
SCRIBBLE OF INK AMID MILES OF
PAPER THAT FEW SCIENTISTS WOULD
INVESTIGATE.
>> BUT JOCELYN ISN'T A
SCIENTIST.
SHE'S AN IMPOSTER, SO SHE'S
WORKING TWICE AS HARD.
IT'S A PULSE, REGULAR LIKE A
HEARTBEAT, A PULSE PRODUCED BY
NO STAR KNOWN TO SCIENCE.
>> BUT THERE WAS WORK TO BE
DONE, PROVE THAT THE SIGNAL IS
REAL, ANALYZE THE SOURCE, FIND
OTHERS LIKE IT AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN CONVINCE HER PROFESSORS TO
TAKE IT, TO TAKE HER SERIOUSLY.
>> JOCELYN BELL HAD MADE ONE OF
THE DISCOVERIES OF THE CENTURY.
SHE HAD DISCOVERED PULSARS,
EMBERS OF BURNING SUPERNOVAS
WITH THE MASS OF THE SUN
SQUEEZED TO THE SIZE OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> LOOK UP FOR A MOMENT.
THEY'RE OUT THERE IN THE
BLACKNESS, STROBING OUT, A
PULSE, THE PERSISTENT HEARTBEAT
OF THE COSMOS.
>> JOURNALISTS DESCENDED AND
ASKED HOW MANY BOYFRIENDS SHE
HAD AND WHETHER SHE'D DESCRIBE
HERSELF AS A BLOND OR BRUNETTE.
IT WAS HER PROFESSOR WHO IS GOT
THE SCIENCE QUESTIONS.
AND THEN A FEW YEARS LATER, IT
WAS HER PROFESSORS WHO GOT THE
NOBEL PRIZE.
>> BUT TONIGHT, WE'RE MAKING
THAT RIGHT.
HERE AT NASA AMES CENTER, WE'RE
AWARDING A SPECIAL PRIZE IN
JUDGMENT PHYSICS FOR THE
DISCOVERY OF PULSARS AND A
LIFETIME OF SCIENTIFIC
LEADERSHIP.
>> TO A WOMAN SCIENTIFICALLY
PROVEN TO BE THE REAL DEAL,
JOCELYN BELL BURNELL.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THIS VERY GREAT
HONOR AND THANK YOU FOR DOING ME
THE HONOR OF BEING HERE THIS
EVENING.
I PLAN TO USE THE MONEY THAT'S
BEEN AWARDED TO ME TO CREATE
RESEARCH STUDENTSHIPS IN PHYSICS
FOR PEOPLE FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
GROUPS IN PHYSICS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> DIVERSITY IS IMPORTANT IN ALL
OUR COMMUNITIES.
ONE OF THE MOST DELIGHTFUL
THINGS IS THAT SOME PEOPLE HAVE
SUBSEQUENTLY BEEN IN TOUCH,
SAYING HOW COULD WE ALSO
CONTRIBUTE AND ADD TO THIS FUND.
SO WE MIGHT HAVE A BREAKTHROUGH,
THANK YOU!
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> EACH WINNER OF THE
BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE TRADITIONALLY
RECEIVES A TROPHY DESIGNED BY
THE ARTIST, AND THIS YEAR THE
FAMOUS SWISS JEWELER AND
WATCHMAKER CHOPARD HAS SPECIALLY
DESIGNED EARRINGS, CUFF LINKS
AND PINS, BLUE SAPPHIRES FOR
PHYSICS, YELLOW SAPPHIRES FOR
LIFE SCIENCES AND MATH.
THEY ARE MADE FROM 100% ETHICAL
GOLD.
CONGRATULATIONS TO ALL THE
LAUREATES FOR THE SHINING
EXAMPLE THEY SET FOR OUR NEXT
GENERATION.
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE FOR
MATHEMATICS AND CHINESE MUSIC
SENSATION PERFORMS "LIGHT YEARS
>>> SCIENCE IS AN INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY AND THE BREAKTHROUGH
PRIZE IS AN INTERNAL EVENT.
GEM IS GOING TO SING A BEAUTIFUL
SONG SHE CREATED FOR THE SCIENCE
FICTION MOVIE "PASSENGERS" ABOUT
A JOURNEY OF LOVE THAT IS
MEASURED IN LIGHT YEARS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, AN AMAZING
TALENT WHO HAS TRAVELED THE
UNIVERSE TO BE HERE TONIGHT
PERFORMING "LIGHT YEARS AWAY"
GEM.
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S MY HONOR TO BE HERE
TONIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> PLEASE WELCOME THE CEO OF
UBER AND STAR OF "WESTWORLD"
TANDI NEWTON.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> PLAYING AN A.I. CHARACTER IN
"WESTWORLD" MAKES ME CONSTANTLY
THINK ABOUT WHAT'S CREATIVE AND
WHAT'S REAL.
THE HONOREES TONIGHT SHOW US
THAT SCIENCE AND MATHEMATICS ARE
BEAUTIFUL WORLDS IN THEMSELVES,
INFINITE AMUSEMENT PARKS FOR THE
MIND.
AND THEY'RE ALSO KEY IN
COMPREHENDING OUR REAL WORLD AND
HOW WE CAN CHANGE IT FOR THE
BETTER.
>> OUR NEXT LAUREATE IS DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO BOTH OF THOSE
WORLDS.
HE'S PLEDGED TO DEVOTE A LARGE
PART OF THE TIME TO MATHEMATICAL
RESEARCH THAT HELPS OUR PLANET
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND AT OTHER TIMES HE ENTERS A
WORLD OF PURE ATTRACTION.
LET'S TAKE A GLIMPSE AT WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO LIVE THERE.
♪♪
>> MATHEMATICIANS FIRST HAVE TO
MAKE CONNECTIONS.
THEN THEY HAVE TO FIND NEW
IDEAS.
MY INTEREST IN MATHEMATICS BEGAN
AT 4 AR 5.
AFS MY PASSION.
-- IT WAS MY PASSION.
WHEN I BEGAN TO WORK --
♪♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> FOR GROUNDBREAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO SEVERAL AREAS
OF MATHEMATICS --
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE FOR
MATHEMATICS IS AWARDED TO --
>> I THANK MY TEACHERS AND
COLLEAGUES AND INSTITUTION IN
FRANCE.
THE BEAUTY OF MATHEMATICS IS
ETERNAL AND FORTUNATELY THE
BEAUTY OF OUR PLANET IS IN GREAT
DANGER.
THIS PLACE REMIND US OF THE
GREAT SUCCESS OF THE PROGRAM.
TO SAVE OUR PLANET, WE NEED SUCH
A COLLECTIVE EFFORT OF BASIC
RESEARCH AND RESEARCH OF CLEAN
ENERGY.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪
>> THE BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE,
SCIENCES CHANGING THE WORLD
[ APPLAUSE ]
>>> WHAT AN EVENING IT HAS BEEN.
THANK YOU ALL HERE AND AT HOME
FOR BEING WITH US.
AND NOW, LET US WELCOME TO THE
STAGE THOSE WHO HAVE LOOKED UP
AND SO DESERVE TO BE LOOKED UP
TO.
THIS YEAR'S BREAKTHROUGH PRIZE
LAUREATES.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪